You have a beautiful smile. Thank
you. I have, when you smile,
I think it's really authentic.
Okay.
A viral New York Times article featured
36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people falling in love.
We wanted to see what would happen if
we asked these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
My name is Charisse Gibbons and I'm
currently single. What do you look for?
Somebody who's a good listener,
someone who's really kind.
I also look for someone who I think can
have deep conversations and can take
things seriously but also can have
fun. No, that's kind of opposite,
but I liked that in someone.
My name is Paula Chung and I'm single,
very single. I feel kind of
nervous, kind of anxious,
kind of excited and I dunno,
uh, I don't know what to expect,
who do meet,
but I think it's going to be a good
time to just get to know a new person.
Have you ever been at a place?
I've never been on a blind date before.
It's my first time.
You like most nervous about?
Maybe the awkwardness that
there'll be in the beginning,
but I feel like once we get talking
then I think that'll go away.
Oh, hi. Nice to meet you.
I see you, Paulo and Charisse. Hi Karen.
Nice to meet you. Nice to meet you.
How are you from La area
originally? I'm from Brazil. Oh,
browsing LADOT but as a
little boy to the bank.
How do you know Portuguese? I let
every two months. Really? Yeah,
but that's pretty much the extent of
what I know. Okay. What about you?
Are you from la? I'm from
Orange County. All right. Um,
moved from the east coast with my
family when I was really young.
So it's pretty much the majority
of what I know. Right. All right.
Do you want some more tea before we begin?
I would love some. All right, cool. Yes,
please. All right. All right.
Do you want to go first? Okay.
So do you have a secret
hunch about how you will die?
I know how I want to die,
like in a way where people feel
like that was pretty legendary.
Know that that's a way to go.
I don't know. I don't know.
Like saving someone's life really
dramatic. Yeah. Korean dramas. Yes.
That's such a good answer.
How about you?
I'm afraid to say it because I don't want
to curse myself. You know what I mean?
No,
don't worry.
I've always been afraid that I would die
from some sort of disease or really bad
car accident. Yeah. Okay.
Hopefully it will be quick.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It was like,
oh shoot, I'm really gonna die in a car
accident and then, and then that's it.
No time to freak out. Yeah. You
can't even freak out. It's so quick.
Let's just leave that to God.
Can I see more to please? Yes.
Stressed.
When did you last sing to
yourself or to someone else?
Like 15 minutes ago in
the car. The car? Yeah.
I was listening to some Whitney Houston.
What about you?
Last time I sang to myself,
maybe in the shower sometimes will,
I'll be driving and my sister's next
to me and then when I started seeing,
she's like, can you stop?
You're embarrassing me. Oh,
does that mean that you can show
me a little dance bay right now?
I think would just be like
a sh a shoulder, you know,
like just like a little shimmy.
Yeah. Just shoot me. Right? Yeah.
You'll be like right next to
another car. I'll be like, hey look,
I think that will be enough.
For what in your life do
you feel most grateful?
I think most grateful for my family.
Very grateful for my parents,
my siblings too.
I think as a whole week,
kind of like compliment each
other and complete each other.
How many siblings do you have? I'm the
oldest. Oh. And then I have a brother,
a sister, and then the little
brother, three boys and one girl.
She suffers a little bit, but that's
crazy. Minus three girls and one boy.
Weird who set up this blind date.
Pretty good casting in this blind date
every year for the past three years,
me and my siblings, I've been doing
a new year's video. Um, just for fun.
That's awesome.
And then we post it on Instagram.
I see this.
Oh my goodness,
you guys do this every year.
We started like three years ago.
Now it's starting to become sort of like
a tradition, but yeah, that's, that's my,
that's me and my siblings. Yeah.
You so much for showing me that
name. Three things. You and your
partner appeared to having common.
Can do this one together.
Korean. I'm half Korean. Um,
we've both been to Brazil. You
mentioned your dad's a pastor. Okay.
My Dad's a pastor to
stop it. Oh my. A. Okay.
You know Richard, cheers. Cheers.
Cheers to the PKS pks out there.
Next question. We're good on this.
If you can wake up tomorrow having
gained any one quality or ability,
what would it be?
Do you have one?
Fearlessness will just so I can see,
see how much of it holds them back.
Maybe not much. Well, but that'd be
interesting. Can I have to rethink mine?
Maybe mom was too superficial. It's
like, whoa. You're listening to though.
Um,
I wish I could fly.
Shoo the feeling of being able to fly.
We'll be awesome.
Is there something that you've
dreamed of doing for a long time?
Why haven't you done it?
I think I haven't do I dream about it?
I guess it's a desire.
Um,
I've wanted to somehow be in the movie.
Even if I die on that scene or I just
come out, I'm like, hey, and it gets shot.
Maybe that's like a small dream, but
yeah, it's, it's something that like, oh,
I think it would be interesting.
You know, similar to yours.
I think mine was doing
something in film or TV.
I've always been afraid to do it
because it felt very vulnerable. Yeah.
We have like one life. Yeah,
that much time. Exactly.
It's got to take the chances and do it.
What is your most terrible memory?
I got arrested at a checkpoint.
I was 19. I remember sitting
in handcuffs on the curb,
like tearing up and just thinking,
how am I going to tell my parents
what's going to happen next?
Big Life lesson for me.
Yeah. And that PK, PK.
Okay. I know you all right.
I'm terrible memory.
The one I can think of right now.
I was on set and I was kind of
like learning everything I did,
like they didn't work out. So
like, Hey, can you shoot this?
Then I would accidentally
step on something. Something
will fall. Oh, so like,
oh my goodness, like who
brought this guy's like, I
almost teared up. I was like,
oh my goodness,
this is so hard.
But then it turned into something really
positive later because I was like, wow.
But I'm so thankful. Despite being
super hard, um, I have this opportunity.
Alternate sharing something you consider
a positive characteristic of your
partner.
I'll start.
I really like your energy and openness.
I think that's a great
characteristic to have.
Just someone who's a good
conversationalist and easy to talk to.
I love the fact that you talked
about like, I want to be fearless,
but I feel like you already are.
Like you do a lot of things.
You don't want to regret it and you
just do it. You're a family guy,
you really care about your family and
it's very evident that you guys are close.
I don't know how many times I talk to
people who are at least openly grateful
for their parents and for their siblings.
So that's cool.
You have a beautiful smile.
Thank you. When you smile,
I think it's really authentic.
What do you go on a second
date with your partner?
Do we time this the answer or,
okay, go first. I'll go first.
I would. There's seems to be
other factors involved in,
in dating. Do you want to
get to know someone? Yeah.
Do you want to hear more about their
story in a safe setting and yeah,
I would totally do that. I would
totally ask you out on a second date.
I feel like, um, we really
connected. We had like what, an hour,
an hour and a half to talk right now,
but I know there's so much
more that you sure. Yeah.
I don't know what's after
this, but I guess like, yeah,
we could set up a time or something. I'm
still here. Yeah, sounds good to me. Cool.
Cool. I want to see another video.
Okay. Yeah. Oh, let me, let me,
let me find it on the last year.
I feel like I've seen this.
I feel like I love your sister.
Yeah, my sister's pretty crazy. I
think you'll get along with my sister.
She and he or she here?
No, she's in Brazil.
She's awesome.
Hey guys, it's Taylor and
I am Jason. What? Billy,
thanks for watching that
episode of tea for two. Uh,
we wanted to ask you another
question for the comments below.
Complete this sentence. I wish I
had someone with whom I could share.
I wish I had someone whom I
can share this video with.
Good one. Let us know your
answer below, and as always,
make sure you subscribe and click to
watch my videos and we will see you next
time
on.
Hey guys, guys who I'm with, Charisse,
we did go on the second date.
Indeed we did. It was
horrible. What? Just kidding.
We'd be talking for hours. Nobody's
here anymore. So everybody's like gone.
But yeah, it was super fun. Yes.
Awesome. Great. Five silly shit.
Bye.